hi
my name is ryan and i'd like to show you
how to get started with google cloud at
no charge
in the next few minutes we'll talk about
how you can get started with the free
trial the free tier and google maps
platform monthly credits ready let's get
started
as you start exploring google cloud you
may want to take advantage of our 90 day
300 free trial
the free trial provides you with free
cloud billing credits to pay for
resources used while you learn about
google cloud
you can activate the free trial if
you've never been a paying customer of
google cloud google maps platform or
firebase and if you haven't previously
signed up for the free trial
to start visit
console.cloud.google.com to open the
google cloud console
this is where you can manage your google
cloud resources directly from the web
log in with the google account of your
choice and accept the terms and
conditions
at the top of your screen you see a
banner about the free trial
click activate to continue
select your country tell us what best
describes your organization or needs and
accept the terms of service
then click continue
after verifying your phone number choose
between a business account or an
individual account
then you're asked to provide credit card
information but don't worry you won't be
charged unless you manually upgrade to a
paid account later on
click start my free trial to activate it
now you have 300 in free credits for the
first 90 days to use across all of
google cloud
you can do things like create new
compute engine virtual machines
deploy serverless applications to cloud
run and set up new cloud sql database
instances
throughout the free trial period your
available credits and days remaining are
displayed in the billing section of the
google cloud console
and if you upgrade to a paid account
later on you'll be able to keep your
cloud resources and use any remaining
credits
beyond the free trial there's also the
free tier which lets you use certain
google cloud products free of charge
within specified monthly usage limits
the free tier is available to both new
and existing users and includes products
like app engine bigquery cloud functions
cloud vision firestore and more
with bigquery for example you get 10
gigabytes of storage per month and one
terabyte of querying per month
if you're using the free trial any usage
of products within the free tier will
not be deducted from your 300 free trial
credits
and if you've already upgraded to a paid
account
any usage of products within the free
tier will not be charged to your credit
card
finally
the google cloud free program includes
200 of monthly credits to use with
google maps platform products
this allows you to explore and use
powerful apis for maps routes and places
so there you have it an overview of how
you can get started with google cloud at
no charge using the free trial the free
tier and google maps platform credits
make sure to check out the other
episodes of google cloud essentials
where we cover the google cloud console
the google cloud sdk
key use cases and more
i can't wait to see what you build with
google cloud
[Music]
you